[Música]
se lo que estáis pensando en maya
titulito pues como mucho más los tengo
otro no numancia roma culturas
enfrentadas este éste se quemó ganó y de
eso vamos a hablar hoy no de culturas
enfrentadas y de ideas enfrentadas mirad
cuando llegué hace más de 20 años al
yacimiento arqueológico de numancia
yo tengo una imagen grabada de las pocas
no porque ya ha llovido bastante que es
la de una conversación que tuvo alfredo
jimeno el director del plan arqueológico
mi maestro y ahora amigo con dos señoras
del pueblecito de garray la radio es el
pueblo que está justo en la ladera del
actual yacimiento de numancia estas
señoras le preguntaban alfredo que si se
podían considerar descendientes de esos
míticos numantinos claro decía bueno si
los numantinos se suicidan antes de caer
y someterse al poder de roma pues no
tenéis filiación genética posible pero
lo interesante es que sí que tenéis un
elemento de unión el elemento de unión
es el paisaje es el territorio y 6 la
misma tierra que son numantinos la
pisaron hace más de dos mil trescientos
años el sol amanece por el mismo moncayo
que amanece hace hace 2300
por tanto de cómo las gentes se han
asentado en este territorio y los
diversos modelos de poblamiento vamos a
hablar hablaremos del territorio que se
conoce como la antigua celtiberia
diríamos que provincial de teruel cuenca
guadalajara y soria ese plano lo estáis
viendo muchos días al día de hoy es el
plano de la espanya vaciada y quizás en
esta charla encontramos algunas de estas
claves de iu porque es desde ese
vaciamiento es decir que cuando hablamos
de poblamiento hablamos de una expresión
cultural más cada pueblo proyecta su
ideología en las maneras más y tan
diversas de hacer la guerra la filosofía
la cultura y el poblamiento es una cosa
más decir porque cada uno plasma esa
ideología también hay que decir una cosa
el pasado por ser pasado no significa
que es peor que el presente solo es una
cosa solo fue distinto en nuestro pasado
están en las raíces de todo nuestro
modelo actual
por tanto menospreciar ese pasado al
final el no entender lo que somos
actualmente por tanto lo que haré será
una comparativa del modelo el de
poblamiento el poblamiento celtibérico
tiene de interesante que es el primer
momento de poblamiento estable en este
territorio
las primeras ciudades y pequeños pueblos
los del timo se asentaron de manera
sostenible y equilibrada en
contraposición con lo que llega después
de la conquista del mundo romano una
ideología que viene de fuera donde se
van a apropiar del territorio lo van a
transformar a su antojo y veremos que
esa transformación llegado a ciertos
momentos de crisis va a generar
problemas
bueno pues claro parafraseando la vida
de brian que nos han dejado en los
romanos nueva parte de un importante
legado cultural el derecho la filosofía
etcétera nos han dejado acueductos
teatros anfiteatros baños públicos
hay que decir que todo está
monumentalización del mundo romano tuvo
un coste si se tiene calculado que a
finales del siglo primero después de
cristo
el porcentaje de esclavitud en el mundo
romano rondaría el 60 por ciento de la
población del imperio ya lo quien hizo
las pirámides
quién está haciendo los estadios en
qatar son buenas buenas preguntas en el
territorio al que nos vamos a de
circunscribir voy a hablar simplemente
de tres ciudades celtibéricas que van a
ser re ocupadas no la ciudad de numancia
la de tiermes y la de uxama no numancia
o sea might germain son ciudades que son
conquistadas son destruidas y
posteriormente vuelven a ser pobladas
por el mundo romano tanto por indígenas
que asumen la ideología del invasor como
por itálicos
bueno pues vemos perfectamente que esas
ciudades son repobladas hay un potente
ciclo de urbanismo se monumental ethan
muchas de ellas donde la extensión de la
ciudad primitiva llega a duplicarse o
triplicarse lo que lleva también a una
dúplica miento de la propia población y
vemos que son ciudades que están siempre
asociados a vías a vías fluviales a ríos
no el duero el lucero el pedró etcétera
pero que en todas esas ciudades llega un
momento donde van a tener problemas y
van a tener que ir a buscar agua muy
lejos en el caso de la ciudad de uxama a
ocho kilómetros al nacimiento del río
pedro eso conlleva evidentemente
transformar el territorio no crean
embalses
cuando hablamos de acueducto no es el de
segovia normalmente no son
canalizaciones que llevan el agua con
pendientes idóneas requieren ingenieros
evidentemente de una tecnología muy
avanzada y llegan incluso a horadar la
propia ciudad por dentro lo que vemos es
el rodamiento de la ciudad no luego con
un registro si subía el agua habría
canales para distribuirla lo mismo pasa
en el sama en usama van tienen dos
acueductos uno de un kilómetro y otro de
veinte van a la cabecera del río ucero a
un sifón que vierten más de 200 litros
al minuto por tanto que vemos pues que
seguramente se sobrepasa el límite para
la gente que lo habitaba y se tienen que
traer el agua de fuera eso también
conlleva cierto grado de monumentalidad
hablamos de que las élites de estas
ciudades ya no viven en casas normales
viven en casas como la que vemos de 800
metros el concepto de metro cuadrado
igual a riqueza en este territorio le
impone el mundo romano luego también hay
un elemento interesante el mundo romano
hace que
lleva a cabo un modelo en el cambio
económico las sociedades celtic américas
en la sociedad es básicamente ganaderas
en esta tierra pero el mundo romano
cambia el modelo a partidos todavía
gustó incide en los modelos agrícolas
para el mundo agrícola no entiendes que
un metro cuadrado da más riqueza de más
productivo pero también es una manera de
pacificar el territorio dicho de otra
manera les quitaron las espadas y dell
dieron azadillas
porque porque al final la gente ociosa
suele dar problemas y los celtíberos
como eran ganaderos tenía mucho tiempo
libre 200 o 500 ovejas tres perros y un
pastor por tanto los numantinos los
celtíberos en general se dedicaban a
labores que se van a poner al mundo
romano esto lo resume muy bien la famosa
frase medieval de la regla de los monjes
benedictinos esa frase del ora et labora
no del reza y trabaja que significa pues
no molestes es decir cuando está rezando
estás en un mundo que no es el tuyo y
cuando estás trabajando está está lo que
tienes que estar normalmente a las
élites lo que le da problemas en la
gente ociosa y más si tiene hambre si
queréis podemos ir al actual barómetro
del cis no la principal preocupación de
los españoles es el paro lo sustancial
tampoco hemos variado hemos variado
tanto pero hay que decir que ese cambio
de modelo económico no fructifica bien
porque porque tenemos territorios muchos
de ellos por encima de los mil metros de
altura en numancia 1100 entiende en
1.230 que quiero decir que las
teóricamente tierras buenas son las que
están al lado de los ríos pero los ríos
se desbordaban generaban humedales zonas
de encharcamiento cuando yo voy en
octubre a intentar rotular esas fincas
tengo medio palmo de agua
que me veo obligado a hacer de forestar
zonas por encima de 1.100 metros y
empiezo ahora ese es el entorno de
numancia en la actualidad la zona
despoblada la zona a la que le quitaron
los los árboles y vemos que en la
actualidad hay cuatro fincas de labor
cultivables
hoy es improductivo con fertilizantes
con arados modernos etcétera imaginaros
hace dos mil trescientos años
qué hace roma pues genera seguramente un
modelo ineficaz para adaptarse a su
propio territorio tan es así que vemos
que en estas ciudades van a empezar a
desarrollarse a finales del siglo
segundo después de cristo que sucede que
cuando el imperio es muy pujante si yo
tengo necesidad de cereal meten 200
carretas desde donde sea el problema es
cuando el imperio da síntomas de crisis
en vez de 200 aparecen 40
entonces vemos ese proceso paulatino de
desaparición de la población estas son
las ciudades celtibéricas repobladas por
el mundo romano que tenemos a finales
del siglo segundo en torno a 20 en el
territorio y con la crisis de bajo
imperio en el siglo cuarto quedan 3
usama tussauds ituriasso que quiero
decir que el mundo romano lo que va a
hacer es imponer un modelo que fue poco
eficaz para el territorio aún teniendo
toda la tecnología el problema es que
cuando el mundo romano da síntomas de
crisis paulatinamente ese modelo no
funciona y el territorio empieza a
deshabilitar se ha llegado hasta tal
punto que como vemos no queda
prácticamente nada a finales del siglo
cuarto inicial del siglo quinto
es bueno que teníamos antes pues quizá
lo más interesante de la cultura
celtibérica es que van a ser los
primeros grupos humanos que se asentaron
de manera continuada en el territorio
esto no significa que antes no hubiese
gente claro que había tenemos
poblamiento neandertales del 40 mil
tenemos gentes del paleolítico neolítico
campos de urnas cable de colectores el
área del bronce el tema es porque esa
gente que sabía que era el mejor sitio
en el caso de numancia alrededor de
numancia 30 asentamientos de etapas pre
previas pero porque no se sientan pues
porque no pueden por los factores hay un
factor climático hacía más frío y
estamos hablando de soria cuenca y
teruel y otro factor que es tecnológico
no tenía la tecnología necesaria para
pasar hay un invierno dicho otra manera
coges un hacha de piedra y poneros a
cortar árboles o un hacha de bronce
bueno pues qué factores cambian para que
el poblamiento estable se produzca y dos
el primero es más importante la
tecnología del hierro del del valle del
ebro los fenicios en el siglo 7
introducen finales del 8 inicial de 7 la
tecnología del hierro claro hace una
hecha de hierro bueno lo que existe
debajo de la motosierra este ruido para
qué sirve
exactamente es la idea las hachas de
hielo de los celtíberos son exactamente
las mismas que dan nuestras así que
hemos mantenido ese modelo pero además
tenemos documentado un cambio climático
hacia más favorable si tengo más
tecnología menos frío pues estos grupos
empezaron a poder aprobar si se podían
quedar a vivir y se pudieron quedar a
vivir el modelo el primer modelo que
fructifica es el que se conoce como el
de la cultura castreña los pequeños
asentamientos en zonas altas economía
ganadera donde lo que llama realmente la
atención son las imponentes murallas
quiero decir para un hábitat donde tengo
diez casas que vivían 40 50 o incluso
hasta 200 personas me plantan una
muralla de 4 metros de ancho y 8 metros
de altura pero son como las de mis cenas
al dónde vais pues evidentemente la
muralla es un elemento defensivo que nos
habla de competitividad territorial
evidentemente pero también es un
elemento de demarcación territorial le
están diciendo al resto de los grupos y
hay mirada que digo que me voy a quedar
aquí a vivir para siempre en lo que el
mensaje que están mandando además la
muralla es un elemento de cohesión
social porque pues hace entre toda la
comunidad
y luego otro elemento de cohesión social
el hierro quiero decir los momentos
previos el bronce generar bronce
necesita de una aleación de dos
minerales que nunca aparecen juntos
cobre y estaño entonces encontró la sal
redes de producción y quien fabrica y
esas redes comerciales genera elites
genera jerarquías
yo tengo esto lo redistribuyó y por
tanto soy más poderoso pero el hierro es
un poco lo de cold con el revólver no
desde que se fabrica el revólver se
acaban las desigualdades sociales bueno
pues esto parece el hielo es abundante
en toda la península ibérica por tanto
una vez que tiene la tecnología todo el
mundo se puede hacer un hacha una espada
o una lanza de hierro ese modelo vemos
que fructifica porque se va
multiplicando hasta que a finales del
siglo cuarto se crean ciudades-estado si
has estado como las que hemos mencionado
la ciudad-estado no solamente la ciudad
en sí no hay una serie de pequeños
asentamiento diseminados elementos que
controla el mundial de comunicación
salinas humedales etcétera y este modelo
si nos introducimos en él pues vemos que
evidentemente muralla y conflictividad
pero cuando vamos a las casas las casas
siguen siendo las mismas que en épocas
anteriores este modelo de casa se hizo
durante s
cientos años si no cambiaron fue porque
no quisieron esta gente viaja en el del
mediterráneo por el mediterráneo del
siglo cuarto antes de cristo no casas de
entre 35 y 50 metros cuadrados acá la
gente es es una casa de numancia cuando
entra en ella nos dice oye para casa más
pequeñita está la casa del pobre porque
vienen de otra casa de 80 metros que es
romana volvemos a esa idea no es que a
ti no vive un romano aquí vivió un
numantino la riqueza esta familia no
está dentro de la casa está fuera de la
ciudad la limpieza es el ganado
evidentemente las casas la casa expresa
otra ideología expresa una ideología de
funcionalidad de hecho esa idea de metro
cuadrado es igual a riqueza bueno pues
nosotros la hemos mantenido todo lo
asumimos pero también tenemos nuestro
pequeño gen
prerromano cuando necesitamos socio que
hacemos pues cogemos una caravana de
cuatro metros cuadrados metemos a los
niños y nos vamos de un mes por aires y
que todavía mantenemos en cierta manera
esa idea no es ejemplo prerromano bueno
pues casas donde son muy funcionales la
primera estancia quizás para este tema
lo más interesante una bodega para
guardar y conservar los alimentos una
primera estancia que es la que más luz
diurna recibe por tanto donde se alzaron
productivas molinos telares mira hacia
los molinos que hemos analizado en
numancia más de la mitad de ellos sólo
muelen un único elemento solo muelen
bellotas con la gente dice ahí va la
bellota porque porque vi la bellota la
asociamos al cerdo y bajamos bueno con
razón evidentemente pero la pregunta no
es qué es la bellota para nosotros hoy
es que era hace dos mil trescientos años
para un numantino pues que era era lo
que había lo que le daba su territorio
de manera natural
de hecho las analíticas palia
ambientales que tenemos nos indican un
territorio densamente poblado de bosques
que se fundamenta en especies como el
pino el roble la sabina y la encina y el
robbie la encina que nolan el bello
estás pues es lo que hay en lo que se
come la lenteja si quieres las comes si
no las dejas
curiosamente bueno no voy a centrar
mucho en esto la bellota tiene un 20% de
proteína más que las actuales pero
también los molinos hemos encontrado
trigo cebada y centeno que seguramente
era importado del territorio base o
donde sabemos que los vacceos el duero
medio importaba en el cereal en botes a
vela por el río duero decir que el duero
era navegable hoy no lo es
y bueno pues sabemos que el trigo la
cebada y el centeno se lo comerían
seguro pero el trigo no el trigo nos
dicen bueno nosotros en los molinos ha
aparecido malteado el tribuno malteado
sólo sirve para hacer una cosa que es
cerveza y esto refuerza la cita que
conocíamos del historiador paulo orosio
señalaba que los numantinos antes del
combate ingerían un brebaje de sabor
áspero pero que les daba calor y fuerza
embriagadora y que este jugo provenía
del fermento del trigo y que se llama
vaca el ya decir que tenemos los que la
marca de la cerveza numantina no laca él
ya esto también nos indica que los
numantinos inventaron la pócima antes
antes que los galos pero claro yo para
conseguir cerveza que intercambió le dan
a no yo la lana la meto al telar le doy
el valor añadido de la mano de obra y
esa prenda que obtengo es la que voy a
intercambiar esa prenda al bien conocida
en sahagún de lana ha llegado hasta
nosotros porque porque los romanos le
impusieron como prenda obligatoria para
sus legiones la reforma que lleva a cabo
mario de hecho ahí está el refrán hasta
el 40 de mayo no te quites ensayó es una
palabra que viene el celtibéricos aún
por tanto un legado más de esta cultura
evidentemente lo que tenemos es toda una
zona de humedales
permite tener una gran riqueza ganadera
porque yo no me hace falta llevarme el
ganado a 100 km hacer atrás permitan cya
sino que simplemente cuando esas zonas
húmedas en el verano se secan tengo
pasto es decir potencia económica
potencia militar y esto lo que hace que
el mundo celtibérico ponga en jaque al
mundo romano desde durante más de 70
años los 70 años que terminan con las
conocidas como segunda generación está
ibérica o el final de abel un numantino
los numantinos resisten durante 20 años
de conflicto y 11 meses de asedio
finalmente los numantinos antes de
querer ser esclavo el de roma lo que
deciden de suicidarse
decir mantiene su libertad eso sí en el
más allá es cuando comienza finaliza la
ciudad pero cuando comienza a su mito
que hemos hecho al final pues comparar
dos modelos un modelo que hemos visto el
de la cultura celtibérica donde al
asentarse al territorio de manera
equilibrada y sostenible ese modelo es
bastante eficiente evidentemente es el
grado por el mundo romano que viene con
una ideología distinta con una gran
potencia que transforma el paisaje el
problema que cuando ese pasaje este
paisaje está transformado cuando el
modelo entra en crisis que lo pagás
insurgentes que no van a tener
suficientes para evitar el territorio
por tanto el territorio se abandona bien
de esta modo solo quiero mostrar un poco
que hagamos una reflexión sobre los
retos que nos esperan en el futuro si
sabemos y hemos visto que hubo gentes
que hace más de dos milenios sí pudieron
asentar el territorio de manera
equilibrada y sostenible porque nosotros
no podemos hacer lo que tenemos los
recursos y tenemos la tecnología
necesario por tanto vemos que el
presente quizás necesite de las viejas
claves del pasado y que estas viejas
claves nos permitan generar nuevos
modelos para asociarnos al medio de una
manera armoniosa y que esos nuevos
modelos quizás sean el mejor legado que
les vamos a dejar a nuestras futuras
generaciones pues nada más y muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]
ah